some guy came up to me and say you John
Stossel yes I hope you die soon
I'm just curious to know how you came to
the conclusions that you have I went to
Princeton where I was taught that big
government would solve poverty and all
other problems basic socialism 101 and
took my first job in Portland Oregon and
became a consumer reporter we'd send a
TV set around to a bunch of repair shops
with all those two and most would just
say Oh lose tube stick it in some would
say Oh we'll have to work on it and
charge us two hundred bucks I would then
go back and say hey would you ever rip
people off like this and they would say
oh no never and I'd say oh yeah well
watch this and play the tape and it was
great television and politicians then
called up and said that was great
television we're gonna create a
Department of Consumer Affairs to fix
this so we did the test again and five
years later same results most people
were honest some people cheated that
made me think well what are these
regulators doing so I went to their
office and they had a big office and
there were people filling out forms and
I started to think about it realizable
this meant that the immigrant had to
learn how to fill out the forms or hire
a lawyer it made everything cost more it
made some people go underground and then
I wandered around and discovered Reason
magazine
David Oz go and with the distilled
spirits Council a friend of mine once
said a journal is this really for real
that the still
do you see any hope for journalists
journalists what has to be done in order
for them to be just have a modicum of
scientific knowledge so that they can
really truly properly interpret reports
and other junk science that happens to
come out I don't know I I mean I was a
psychology student I always had some
interest in science I never took a
journalism course I just think there's
some left-brain right-brain thing and
the kind of analytical minds that go
into business and science don't go into
law and journalism the people who go
into that or they're like Bill Clinton I
feel your pain they are the motors and
they are often clueless about analyzing
things I'm wondering maybe you didn't
have a choice but because you were
associated with that Fox brand people
must really hate you who liked you
before her liberal friends would have
been better if you'd been on MSNBC
something counterintuitive or did you
think about that
I'm curious sure I would have thought
about that but I don't think they would
have hired me I mean when I came out as
a libertarian and thought about what my
options were I thought who's gonna buy
this between Republicans and Democrats I
thought the best shot are the Liberals
because the social conservatives you
know if I'm saying homosexuality is fine
or people ought to be able to get high
that just violates their religious
principles and they can't bend on that
but the Liberals I ought in reality the
fall of the Soviet Union ought to have
taught them that their ideas are moronic
and they should stop it there are people
in my neighborhood some guy came up to
me and say 'hey john stossel yes i hope
you die soon
okay my question it's about another one
of your books you talk about the price
of gasoline compared to the price of ice
cream and bottled water that the price
of those food items are actually more
than the gasoline but when does someone
argue that people can choose whether or
not they want ice cream or if they want
bottled water they could get it from the
tap I mean they're more limited as to
like whether they can have gasoline
because we know we need to get to work
you know not everyone can I ride a
bicycle to work and so forth so sure but
I would say so what just because people
need it doesn't mean it ought to be free
think what it takes to get us a gallon
of gas they drill this stuff now in war
zones where their lives are at risk
the drills go seven miles into the
ground they Bend they suck the stuff up
they put it in pipelines that cost
billions of dollars just put ships that
cost a billion hundreds of millions of
dollars ship it to the United States
where it has to be refined and at least
three types of gasoline meet all these
environmental rules and then be put in
trucks that cost $100,000 each and go to
gas stations where they have to have all
this expensive equipment so we don't
blow ourselves up and it costs less per
ounce than the bottled water or ice
cream that they sell at these gas
stations I'm impressed by that I think
the oil companies are freaking heroes
and should be celebrated and the fact
that we need gasoline shouldn't matter
it's you still need people who will
bring it to us and the price mechanism
is the best way to distribute that I
think you're probably one of the best
people the Liberty movement has in terms
of communicating complex economic ideas
to a wide audience what advice would you
have for folks who are trying to
communicate these ideas to a wider
audience how do you do that in a way
that's strategic that's intelligent but
also appeals to a wider array of people
than just people who are pumped about
Hayek and
Milton Friedman I was not a good student
and I'm easily bored and that I think
helped me be successful in television I
felt if I wanted people to pay attention
to this I gotta use sound and picture
and simple words you have new
opportunities that I didn't have and
that no one's had before
think about the Rodney King beating and
what that said but what how that
enlighten people about police attitudes
how a few seconds caught on tape how
powerful that is anybody can make a
video put it on YouTube